stunning hypocrisy from the corrupt
democrats who rule over crime-ridden
chicago as homicides skyrocket in the
windy city up 29 year-to-date since 2020
mayor lori lightfoot can sleep soundly
at night thanks to her secret army of
cops
in 2020 a special unit of ready 70
officers was reportedly created to keep
the mayor safe in addition to the normal
20 cop strong security detail she
already has
this is really rich considering
lightfoot was a major advocate for
cutting funding to police
it is essential that the police
department take responsibility for the
way in which it's policed and the way in
which it has in many instances alienated
people of color particularly african
americans in this city we live in a city
that is traumatized by a long history of
police violence and misconduct we can't
rely upon the police to provide public
safety
judge why would you need 70 officers to
protect
someone like that listen to this i am
going to shock you
i have spoken to two
rather significant high-level people in
law enforcement
and they tell me what i didn't expect i
would be saying and that is that the
number 71 is not that unusual because
you've got 24 7 operation okay
uh and so it's around the clock
and you've also got uh the mayor's house
her security detail and city hall
so if you think about that that's a lot
of people assigned now that doesn't mean
that i forgive her for all her lunacy
because i think that what she has done
is terrible her job is instead of
blaming the police and saying the city
of chicago is traumatized because of the
police she should know from her own
statistics that when she stopped
defunding the police and decided to
somewhat up the budget from not to where
it was but a little bit from where she
defunded it crime started to go down a
teeny bit
she understands that police on the
streets are what stops crime and so
she has a right to have her own you know
security detail eye to security detail
when i was a d.a i mean it is it's
serious business and only they know what
is appropriate that's the
i
it's easy to talk about defunding the
police when you've got a your own
brigade right i mean this i mean this
reminds me exactly of like
tv hosts talking about how important the
shutdowns were because we still did our
shows like she has she never had to deal
with the consequences she never had to
talk to the victims or or worry about
crime because it didn't touch her this
has been a problem with every in every
city they have to be stripped of this
stuff the moment that they say that
they're going to defund something they
should be stripped of it immediately
because because they've got a lit they
should walk the walk
right that's a different issue i mean
the question is is 71 appropriate for
your house for the mayor's office and
your personal detail the answer is yes
but i agree with you people like corey
bush i mean we want to defund the police
we hate the police they're responsible
and yet you're spending two hundred
thousand dollars a year whatever the
crazy number is it's wrong joe biden's
still really on the defensive about to
hold to fund the police then so he's
throwing a lot of money at the issue and
he was asked about it i'm not sure if he
had a note card for this answer but
let's listen dana
is any of it related to political
pressure from republicans saying that
democrats are soft on crime that you
know that you guys are creating to the
left and that kind of fascinating when i
first got elected i was being beat up
because i supported the police too much
for the previous 30 years
now
it's what i think
oh what a creepy one
it's so creepy it is i think that is
what he thinks and i don't think it is
before political reasons that he has put
this in the budget maybe a little bit
but the his political problems for the
midterms aren't necessarily on the right
or in the center his problems are on the
left remember what aoc congresswoman
alexandria ocasio-cortez said last week
nobody on the left is energized by him
nobody wants to get out there and
campaign they feel disappointed by him
and midterm elections are about your
base and he needs something for the base
that's why he put in the billionaire's
tax which probably won't go anywhere
and it was easy for him to say give mor
police money to police i think he
personally believes it but all the
people on his left do not piers you went
out and did a man on the street segment
which we're going to be airing tonight
at seven o'clock were you assaulted
immediately upon leaving the building by
all these people out here in new york
city i've celebrated would be this
celebrated you know what this reminds me
of though this this defunder policing
it's the worst political slogan i think
imaginable you know like 99 of people
that are here again what the hell are
you talking about so politically it's a
complete fiasco but if there's one thing
that is guaranteed doesn't matter where
you are in the world guaranteed to
enrage an electorate it is elected
officials preaching one thing and doing
the complete opposite and we've got a
very interesting case in the uk right
now with partygate where boris johnson
the prime minister and his entire
downing street staff having
announced all these lock down rules for
the country and very draconian
restrictions for you know 18 months it
turned out they were partying breaking
their own restrictions every single week
in fact 20 of them got fined today we
don't know who they are yet it may even
include boris johnson in which case his
own position might become untenable but
the rage is not about the fact they were
having parties and the rage about this
is not that mayor lightfoot is having
her own security i think most people
would accept she needs it the rage is
the brazen hypocrisy i'd like to defund
hypocrisy because that is a corrosive
thing for any elected official it's the
fact that she was out there saying we
don't need so many police
but actually i do
you don't so you can all suffer the
crime you know my youngest son is
currently at university in chicago and
he says he's scary out there yeah is
that because he's your son or is it a
big condition that's the best thing
about being in chicago people are
stopping him in the street saying wow i
love your dad no right
you'll see that on the video later
unless you're better today have you yeah
we're gonna make some minutes what's up
with boris's hair yes
here's the thing about boris's hair i've
seen him i've seen him do this i did a
show called question time panel show in
uk about politics and it was all
straight when he arrived and kept
and i watched him look around like that
and then ruffle it up
it's completely deliberate as most
things are with water does he think it
advantages him yes he thinks the sort of
you know slightly wild scatty he sees
himself as a kind of heath liv
he spends money
on making his hair look like that as we
do yeah
oh speak for yourself
[Laughter]
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else